ladies and gentlemen the future is here
you can now get rich quick
you can make a million dollars you can
be a millionaire thanks to get rich tick
tock
but you need one thing knowledge this
only
small small issue small issue in order
to become a millionaire with fintalk
uh you need to first be a billionaire
that's basically it
just bought virtual real estate yeah you
heard me right
you heard me right boys hey 12 year old
number one wealth advisor
i'm sorry it shouldn't there be an age
limit for
wealth advice i don't i think there has
to be some regulation please
there's a platform called earth 2 where
you can buy real estate that doesn't
even exist
yeah and the profits you make say with
me
don't even exist a lot of people have
been talking about it recently so i
bought
13 worth and overnight it turned to over
50 dollars
i like i was like i literally got 270
gain overnight
lmao hey good luck getting your money
out of the
of earth too buddy that's totally not
gonna flop
oh my gosh well welcome guys uh where's
the intro please roll the intro
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla
and today as you know we're doing
another stocks with tick tocks
more great advice i hate 401ks this is
kris krohn we're gonna be hearing a lot
from him today max out your 401k
could be the dumbest advice that i've
ever heard for anyone that wants to take
financial control of their future
why but chris it's free money
you do max contribution and the company
matches you it's awesome like are you
kidding me
i love when people mimic someone else
that they want to seem stupid so they
make a baby voice
and then they go are you kidding me dude
hey just cause you make the baby voice
doesn't mean you're right
it is great to max out your 401k you
idiot i can't believe they just give
anyone like this
the ability to go tell people how to
make money do you guys realize this guy
has an sec complaint against him
yeah that's a thing he had to pay 000 to
settle it
oh why was that oh he had a scheme
before this
so you think all you see is this guy
with like 700 000 followers on tick tock
you think he's some big genius
bro he's going against like all
financial advice
ever first of all i give you my money
and i'm never gonna see it for decades
it's called an investment chris you
invest in real estate
that's what happens in real estate
okay i better just move on guys i
it's clear we're not gonna get anywhere
here like why would i give that to you
even if you're matching it it's not real
it's fake funny money
it's not though everything you've said
here is wrong
it's not fake funny it's re it's real
actual money
what dude
anyone can get on tick tock i hope i
pray
that any of my audience nobody listens
to tick tock for financial advice
come on man [ __ ] listen if you're new
here to coffeezilla welcome to the club
first of all and then just
go ahead take take get your phone out
let's do it together why not
get your phone out here you go let's
open up tick tock
okay we got it and then delete it all
together now
delete it it's not worth your time there
you go
and i love how they think like the more
passionate and outlandish they are
the more correct they are no dude you're
just uninformed which is kind of
hilarious when you see this next part
my mentor after seven years and a
million dollars to paying him the most
powerful thing he ever taught me was
chris
the most dangerous information is what
you don't know okay
let's break that down shall we first of
all you paid a guy a million dollars for
your mentorship
uh chris
maybe you should pay attention some
coffees ella i think you could have done
a lot better if you'd invested that into
real estate but
but the most ironic part of this is that
he's saying the most dangerous thing is
what you don't know
and then he proceeds to rant about a
bunch of things he has no clue about
do you think this guy understands the
stock market when his big advice
is 401ks index funds anything in the
stock market don't believe in it
just believe in uh real estate because
real estate never goes down guys you can
never fail in real estate
real estate's the only way to get rich
with real estate
you start here and then it'll just
slowly slowly
go up i mean look i'm not even real
estate's fine it's just one of many
options but it's hilarious this guy
number one thing the number one thing
most dangerous thing is what you don't
know and then you go and talk about a
thing
a bunch of things you don't know about
now of course let's be honest you know
why he's doing this right you know why
he's selling you all this information
this year next year and the year after
i've got a special event i'm doing april
13th
it's a two-hour master class i'm going
to teach you how to take 50 grand
it's just a pitch for your stupid
masterclass
so yeah i don't even know if he believes
in this stuff i mean he just sells it
listen if he was so great at it
why wouldn't he just do it if he made so
much money at it why wouldn't he just
again
do it and listen before you say stephen
wait what are you talking about like of
course he'd want to do this
with uh get extra money look at this he
says he can get
annual 25 annual rois
uh that's what this says and he gives
you a little chart to show you that uh
basically the stock market's a scam
because it only gets you six percent a
year meanwhile oh my gosh you're gonna
get 25 percent a year in the stock
market
okay if that's true kris krohn would
never be selling
a course if he could get 25 annually in
the stock uh in the real estate
he'd never sell a course because he'd be
making ungodly amounts of money focusing
on his real estate empire so the very
fact he's selling you some stupid master
class
should be a dead giveaway now here's
another gem from kris krohn
uh he says that you can get a bunch of
houses for nothing
it's the best real estate year we'll see
for the next decade and i'm going to
show you how to buy 12 homes
without any money or credit if you
attend my event january 12th 13th and
14th in the evenings
12 homes with no money down have you
lost your mind of course it gets worse
what's up
what about low cost index funds
financial influences be like
get low cost index funds because they're
low cost with little regard to how they
perform as a retirement plan
but guess what they freaking suck as
retirement plans
earth to the human wet wipe uh people do
pay attention to how they perform
that's literally why they people suggest
them they've done the math
they go hey this is a great option it
consistently performs
unlike many other investments now this
guy
behind the scenes of course he wants to
sell you on his little uh
little insurance scheme so don't pay
attention to people like this anytime
you hear somebody going
oh low cost index funds suck they suck
hey 401k suck
get ready get your wallet out because
they're about to try to charge it up
now of course guys no video would be
complete
without uh giving equal opportunity to
the women grifters
of tick tock we got to give equal
opportunity so ladies and gentlemen
without further ado
how do you get rich faster real estate
or
ai this should be good how do you get
rich faster through real estate or ai
let's see
this is artificial intelligence that i
use and look at this if you started 2019
until today two years later with only
ten thousand dollar in balance
you would have made a thousand two
hundred percent return and that would
have left you with a hundred
thirty three thousand dollars in a year
guys what do you
do you see anything wrong with this two
years
twelve hundred percent roi are any alarm
bells going off for you i swear dude
we've gone so off the deep end
of what's like even possible you've
gotten to this point where people
are literally pitching fraud schemes i
mean think about this dude somebody's
telling you put all your money
in some random pop-up fly-by-night
company you never heard of
for their proprietary ai guys because if
i use enough buzzwords maybe you'll
believe i'm on the
cutting edge of finance it's so goofy
man and i can't believe this lady is
like pitching this and she's
literally getting away with it she's a
nobody but of course on tick tock
she's a wealth advisor make 274 a day
how can you do that so what i did was i
learned how to trade the stock market
i learned how to trade the forex market
i learned how to trade the crypto market
i learned how to trade binary options
guys
she self admits to being a waitress six
months ago
now there's no problem with that i was a
waiter too but you didn't learn
stocks forex crypto and binary markets
in six months i'm sorry you did
it it's so insane to me because people
are seeing this and
they're really getting tricked misled
and it's like guys just look at how
crazy these people are
they're they're nuts they're they don't
know anything so please don't sign up
for this stuff guys please
you will make me very very sad if you
join these people's masterminds
um it really is the blind leading the
blind the info
course business has no regulation anyone
can just project themselves as an expert
and uh yeah don't listen all right well
that's basically it
save your stimis put it in a low cost
index fund no matter what curtis ray
says
and uh yeah that's it for now i hope
that you had fun watching the
this insanity and it enraged you as much
as it did me
i'll see you guys next time see ya
up smell the coffee